The number of adolescents and young adults using marijuana on a regular basis is increasing, and some states are legalizing recreational marijuana. But regulating its use among young people is a challenge that needs to be considered in light of scientific research, says neuropsychologist Krista Lizdahl. In this episode, she talks about why chronic marijuana use is especially toxic to teenagers' brains, even more so now than a few decades ago. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of it. psychology. Psychologist Krista Lizdahl is director of the brain imaging and
经常使用大麻的青少年和年轻人数量正在增加，一些州也在将娱乐性大麻合法化。但是，神经心理学家克里斯塔·利兹达尔（Krista Lizdahl）表示，在科学研究的背景下，监管年轻人对大麻的使用是一个需要考虑的挑战。在本期节目中，她将探讨为什么长期使用大麻对青少年的大脑尤其具有毒性，而且现在比几十年前更甚。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这里是《心理学解密》（Speaking of Psychology）。心理学家克里斯塔·利兹达尔是威斯康星大学密尔沃基分校脑成像和
neuropsychology laboratory at the University of Wisconsin, Milwaukee. Using magnetic resonance imaging or MRI, she studies the neurocognitive consequences of chronic drug use on the brains of teenagers and young adults. Welcome Dr. Lizdahl. Thank you. It's a pleasure to be here. Years ago there was a television public service announcement aimed at teenagers that showed an egg frying in a pen. You remember that? And announcer saying this is your brain on drugs. Very dramatic. It was memorable to a lot of kids of that generation. Do you think people, specifically teenagers, really understand what marijuana you specifically can do to their brains? And is it
神经心理学实验室的主任。她利用磁共振成像（MRI）研究长期吸毒对青少年大脑的神经认知后果。欢迎您，利兹达尔博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。多年前，曾有一个针对青少年的电视公益广告，展示了一个平底锅里煎鸡蛋的画面。你还记得吗？播音员说，这就是吸毒后的你的大脑。非常戏剧化。这给那一代的许多孩子留下了深刻的印象。你认为人们，特别是青少年，真的明白他们所使用的大麻究竟对他们的大脑有什么影响吗？并且它在
increasing among teenagers? So for the first question, do they understand what it really does to the brain? I would have to say for the vast majority, no, there's not a good understanding. In fact, a lot of people that I talk to, it seems like they don't even understand the concept that marijuana is a drug that gets in the brain, and that's where the effects come from. A lot of times the attitude is that, you know, marijuana is just an herb, why would it affect you? It's safe as though it's something like mint, you know, it's not a psychoactive drug. The other question is, is marijuana use increasing among teens?
青少年中是否在增加？关于第一个问题，他们是否明白它对大脑的实际影响？我不得不说，绝大多数人都没有，并没有很好的理解。事实上，和我交谈过的许多人似乎甚至不理解大麻是一种能进入大脑的药物这一概念，这正是其影响的来源。很多时候，人们的态度是，你知道，大麻只是一种草药，为什么它会影响你？它很安全，就像薄荷一样，你知道，它不是一种精神活性药物。另一个问题是，大麻在青少年中的使用是否在增加？
We have seen an increase, actually, specifically in heavy regular use, which is most alarming to me because that's when we see more of the negative health effects. So since we've had the highest rates since the 1980s, in the last five years or so, it's gone up from about 2% of high school seniors using daily all the way up to almost 7%. Daily. Daily. Wow. And so there's more teenagers using marijuana daily than they are using alcohol daily. And about 23% of high school seniors are using in the past month.
我们确实看到了增长，实际上，特别是在高频常规使用方面，这让我最感到担忧，因为正是在这个时候，我们会看到更多的负面健康影响。因此，自从我们经历了20世纪80年代以来的最高比率以来，在过去五年左右的时间里，高中高年级学生每天使用大麻的比率从大约2%一直上升到近7%。每天。每天。哇。因此，每天使用大麻的青少年比每天饮酒的青少年还要多。大约有23%的高中高年级学生在过去一个月里使用过。
And that's now surpassed nicotine use. And so it's second only to alcohol. Many jurisdictions amongst all this are considering decriminalizing marijuana, not just medical marijuana, but recreational marijuana. What sort of information should policymakers have when they consider making this drug available to the general public? Some of the things that I've thought about in weighing the policy issues is the first question we need to ask is, is the current policy working in reducing marijuana use? Well, already we see that attitudes relating to marijuana have gotten softer and people, for the most part, including teenagers, don't see it as very dangerous.
这现在已经超过了尼古丁的使用量。因此，它仅次于酒精。在所有这些背景下，许多司法管辖区正在考虑将大麻非罪化，不仅是医用大麻，还有娱乐性大麻。当决策者考虑向普通公众提供这种药物时，他们应该掌握什么样的信息？我在权衡政策问题时考虑的事情之一，我们需要问的第一个问题是，当前的政策在减少大麻使用方面是否有效？好吧，我们已经看到，与大麻相关的态度已经变得温和，人们（在很大程度上，包括青少年）不再认为它非常危险。
And when we see those attitude shift, we see marijuana use go up. And so in some ways, this is not even tied to policy changes. It's more about just the kind of the culture and belief system surrounding marijuana. And so in the states that have kind of looser beliefs about marijuana or believe it safer are more likely to pass the legislation for medical marijuana or decriminalization or even legalization. So that's one question is, is it actually one? working our current prohibition policy. And a lot of people would say it's not, it is somewhat
当我们看到这种态度发生转变时，我们就会看到大麻的使用量上升。因此，在某种程度上，这甚至与政策变化无关。它更多地关乎围绕大麻的文化和信仰体系。因此，在对大麻持有更宽松信念或认为大麻更安全的州，更有可能通过医用大麻、非罪化甚至合法化的立法。所以这是一个问题，即我们的禁毒政策是否真的有效。许多人会说并非如此，它在某种程度上
effective at reducing use, but right now we see use going up either way with at least the majority of the state still having prohibition. The other question that people have to consider when making these decisions is, is the current policy potentially doing harm? And we do see that with the Bureau of Justice Statistics about 250,000 adults being arrested for possession charges of marijuana, this does cost a lot of money. One of the bigger concerns brought up by some of my colleagues, including people like Dr. Carl Hart, is that there's a very large racial bias in this. So African Americans are four times more likely throughout the country to be arrested compared to Caucasians. And federally, Hispanics are more likely to be arrested. They also get more severe sentencing.
在减少使用方面是有效的，但现在我们看到，即使大多数州仍然实行禁毒，大麻的使用量无论如何都在上升。人们在做出这些决定时必须考虑的另一个问题是，现行政策是否可能造成危害。我们从美国司法统计局的数据中确实看到，大约有25万名成年人因持有大麻而被捕，这确实花费了大量资金。由我的几位同事（包括卡尔·哈特博士等人）提出的一大担忧是，这其中存在非常大的种族偏见。因此，非裔美国人在全国范围内被捕的可能性是白人的四倍。在联邦层面，西班牙裔更有可能被捕。他们还会受到更严厉的判决。
And so one thing to balance out is, is prohibition doing harm? And so there is an argument that it is doing some harm as far as racial discrimination in arrests and sentencing. And so then the question is, what are the alternatives? So a lot of people have come out to support decriminalization, and one of the strengths of that is that it gets rid of some of this criminal justice issue and the cost of putting people in prisons. America has more people in prisons than any other country. This isn't my specialty, but it's clearly an issue that needs to be addressed.
因此，需要权衡的一件事是，禁毒是否正在造成危害？因此，有一种观点认为，它在逮捕和判决中的种族歧视方面确实造成了一些危害。那么问题来了，有什么替代方案？因此，许多人站出来支持非罪化，其优势之一是它摆脱了部分刑事司法问题以及将人们送入监狱的成本。美国的监狱关押人数比世界上任何其他国家都多。这不是我的专业，但这显然是一个需要解决的问题。
more on the public health side that is my specialty is if jurisdictions consider either decriminalization and especially legalization, they have to really get ahead of the legislation and before they even put it into place, consider how are they going to prevent adolescent and emerging adult, so youth use, how are they going to prevent that, how are they going to get it on the people who need treatment, how well are they going to fund prevention and treatment? And then there's other things like how are you going to limit advertising? How are you going to limit potency? How are you going to make sure that the marijuana is clean and doesn't have other things like mold in it? So what are some of the major changes happening in the brains of chronic marijuana users
更多地在公共卫生方面，这是我的专业，如果司法管辖区考虑非罪化特别是合法化，他们必须真正走在立法的前面，甚至在实施之前，就要考虑他们将如何防止青少年和刚成年的年轻人使用，他们将如何接触到需要治疗的人，他们将如何资助预防和治疗？然后还有其他事情，比如你将如何限制广告？你将如何限制效力？你将如何确保大麻是干净的并且没有霉菌等其他东西？那么，慢性大麻使用者的脑海中正在发生哪些主要变化
and how do they affect their mental abilities? Yeah, so my area is neuropsychology and neuroimaging and I've spent the last 15 years or so studying how chronic regular use. So the first thing is I need to define that. So that's at least weekly use all the way up to multiple times a day. And what we see is the bigger effects in cognition are in younger people. One of the reasons we think this is happening is that the adolescent brain isn't mature until about the mid-20s. There's a lot of neurodevelopment going on in the connectivity, in the structure of the brain.
以及它们如何影响他们的心理能力？是的，所以我的领域是神经心理学和神经影像学，我花了大约过去15年的时间研究长期规律使用。首先，我需要定义这一点。这就是至少每周使用一次，直到每天多次。我们看到，对认知影响更大的是年轻人。我们认为发生这种情况的原因之一是，青少年大脑直到25岁左右才成熟。在连接和大脑结构方面有很多神经发育
that really doesn't peak about age 25. Now, people start using drugs around age 16, 17 on average. It's not an adult onset. The peak use is in teenage years and young adult years. And if you start using before age 18, you're at double the risk for developing a use disorder. And so I consider addiction a teenage onset disorder. And so I've looked at how chronic marijuana, repeated marijuana use, these brains. And we do see significant changes in verbal memory, the ability to control impulses,
直到25岁左右才真正达到顶峰。现在，人们平均在16、17岁左右开始吸毒。这不是成年期发作。使用的高峰期是在十几岁和刚成年的时候。如果你在18岁之前开始使用，你患上使用障碍的风险就会加倍。因此，我认为成瘾是一种青少年发作的障碍。因此，我研究了慢性大麻、重复使用大麻对这些大脑的影响。我们确实看到语言记忆、控制冲动的能力发生了显著变化，
decision-making, the ability to kind of hold information in mind and manipulate it, the ability to sustain your attention over time. And the other thing that we see is increased mood symptoms, including depression and anxiety, and also increased problems with sleep. Now, a lot of these things get better if people stop using. And in fact, we have evidence that. that if teenagers stop using for at least a month, we see that their sleep quality improves, and we also see that some of the cognitive functioning improves, although not all of it. And there is a longitudinal study showing that if you start before 18, again, using regularly, not just a couple times, but at least once a week, that we see the biggest drop in IQ,
决策能力、将信息保留在脑海中并对其进行操作的能力、随时间维持注意力的能力。我们看到的另一件事是情绪症状增加，包括抑郁和焦虑，以及睡眠问题的增加。现在，如果人们停止使用，其中许多事情会好转。事实上，我们有证据表明。如果青少年停止吸毒至少一个月，我们会发现他们的睡眠质量有所改善，我们还发现部分认知功能有所改善，尽管并非全部。一项纵向研究表明，如果你在18岁之前开始，同样是定期使用，不仅仅是几次，而是至少每周一次，我们会看到智商下降幅度最大，
eight points IQ loss. That's very significant. And the people who used in their teens never as adults, even though they didn't use, as adulthood never got back on the trajectory you would have predicted. Now that study is by Meyer and colleagues. One problem with it is that in the end it was a pretty small sample size of the teenage regular use onset. And so when you're thinking policy it's not just the heavy users although they drive the majority of the market and that's why I'm concerned and everyone's talking about adults but frankly people start using in their teens and
智商下降了八分。这非常显著。那些在青少年时期使用过大麻的人，到了成年期即使不再使用，也从未恢复到你所预测的发展轨迹上。现在这项研究是由迈尔（Meyer）及其同事进行的。它存在的一个问题是，最后对于青少年规律使用开始的样本量相当小。因此，当你考虑政策时，它不仅仅是重度使用者，尽管他们推动了绝大多数市场，这也是我关心的原因，每个人都在谈论成年人，但坦率地说，人们在青少年时期就开始使用，
the heaviest users are in their teens and young adults. So if we change adult policy, we really need to make sure that we have all the safeguards in place to protect use in teens. And I want parents and teachers and physicians to start taking marijuana use seriously and young people and really educate them that if they use regularly, they may be changing the structure of their brain and they may not reach their full potential. Now, tetrahydro-canabinol commonly called THC, I'm glad I got that out of my system, is the major psychoactive chemical in marijuana. Why is it important to consider the potency of these drugs? It's a really great question.
而最重度使用者正是青少年和年轻人。因此，如果我们改变针对成年人的政策，我们真的需要确保我们制定了所有保障措施，以保护青少年不使用大麻。我希望父母、老师和医生开始认真对待青少年使用大麻的问题，并真正教育他们，如果他们经常使用，他们可能会改变大脑结构，并且可能无法发挥他们的全部潜力。现在，四氢大麻酚通常被称为THC，我很高兴我把它说出来了，它是大麻中的主要精神活性化学物质。为什么考虑这些药物的效力很重要？这是一个非常棒的问题。
What we've seen over the past 20 years or so is that the average THC content in marijuana joints was about 5, 6, 7%. It is now up to 15 to 18%. And they're also making products where basically they're burning oils down and purifying them down to almost 28% THC. Now, it's possible that people could be smoking a joint with high THC content and just inhale less to kind of control that dose, although we need more evidence that that's what they're actually doing. The other problem of this, though, is that as they're kind of creating these strains with really high THC, what's happened is another component of marijuana called cannabidiol is going down. And what we know is cannabodial actually has opposing effects to THC in the brain. And it seems to be neuroprotective. It actually reduces anxiety. And there are some human studies that show if someone is smoking
在过去20年左右的时间里，我们看到大麻烟卷中的平均四氢大麻酚（THC）含量约为5%、6%、7%。现在已经上升到15%到18%。他们还在制造这样的产品：基本上是将油煮沸并提纯，使其THC含量达到近28%。现在，人们有可能吸食THC含量高的大麻烟卷，只是吸入较少来控制剂量，尽管我们需要更多证据证明这确实是他们正在做的事情。然而，这带来的另一个问题是，随着他们制造出THC含量极高的这些品种，大麻的另一个成分大麻二酚（CBD）却在下降。我们所知道的是，大麻二酚在大脑中实际上具有与THC相反的作用。而且它似乎具有神经保护作用。它实际上可以减少焦虑。有一些人类研究表明，如果有人在吸食
marijuana with high content of cannibalial, then they have fewer cognitive effects, both while they're smoking and then a few days later. We need more evidence to figure out, like, what is the safer ratio of THC versus cannabis dial? But this is something that a lot of government agencies are really considering. So, for example, the Netherlands are thinking about capping the THC levels at 15 percent, and other folks like myself are really trying to push them to also consider increasing the minimum requirement of cannibial. What about medical marijuana? Does that have a high THC count or is that regulated at all? It is there's different strains. You know, people basically sell and market these different strains. Some of them have very high THC content. Some of them have very
大麻二酚含量很高的大麻，那么他们的认知影响就会减少，无论是在吸食时还是几天后。我们需要更多的证据来弄清楚，比如THC与大麻二酚更安全的比例是多少？但这是许多政府机构正在认真考虑的事情。例如，荷兰正在考虑将THC水平限制在15%，而像我这样的其他人则真诚地敦促他们同时考虑提高大麻二酚的最低要求。医用大麻怎么样？它的THC含量高吗？还是受到了某种监管？是的，有不同的品种。你知道，人们基本上在销售和推销这些不同的品种。有些品种的THC含量非常高。有些品种
low. There are some strains that are marketed as, as really high cannabodial, like Charlotte's Web, for example. although, you know, these aren't regulated. Right. And it's hard. Science hasn't exactly gotten on board to test all of these and to look at the psychopharmacology. There are clinical trials that control the levels of THC and cannabodial. And I actually really strongly support that as far as the medicinal side goes, that science
很低。有些品种被宣传为大麻二酚含量非常高，例如“夏洛特的网”（Charlotte's Web）。虽然，你知道，这些并没有受到监管。是的。这很难。科学界还没有完全加入进来测试所有这些并研究其精神药理学。有一些临床试验控制了THC和大麻二酚的水平。我实际上非常强烈地支持这一点，就药用方面而言，科学
and medicine lead the way in this. And we do clinical trials just like any other medication and that we don't, you know, have parents out there. trying to pick different cannabinoid oils and things like that for their children when there's really very little evidence to back it on safety profiles and the therapeutic dose. So we really, we need more research and we need to get ahead of that. I actually think it's slightly ridiculous that we just have people smoking pot that they get from growers as a medicine. Now, many people are under the assumption that marijuana is not addictive. You can't be
和医学走在前列。我们像任何其他药物一样进行临床试验，我们不会让父母们。为了他们的孩子去尝试挑选不同的的大麻素油之类的东西，而实际上几乎没有证据支持其安全性和治疗剂量。所以我们真的，我们需要更多的研究，我们需要走在前面。我甚至觉得，我们只是让人们把从种植者那里买来的大麻当药抽，这有点荒谬。
addicted to it. It's just not like alcohol, it's not like cigarettes, but so is it? There's actually very strong evidence that marijuana is addictive and any, pretty much any scientists that are talking about policy, no one denies that it's addictive. What we see in the general adult population is of those who use marijuana, 9% show a cannabis use disorder. So problems related and signs of addiction. What we see in teenagers, however, is if you start smoking before, say, the rate is closer to 18% rates of addiction. And actually, if you start smoking in the more like 14, 15, you have even higher rates like 25% who try it become addicted. So there are these sensitive periods where you're more likely to develop a cannabis use disorder.
现在，许多人误以为大麻不上瘾。你不可能对它上瘾。它不像酒精，也不像香烟，但真的是这样吗？实际上有非常有力的证据表明大麻是会成瘾的，任何讨论政策的科学家，没有人否认它是会成瘾的。我们在普通成年人口中看到的是，在使用大麻的人中，有9%表现出大麻使用障碍。即与成瘾相关的问题和迹象。然而，我们在青少年中看到的是，如果你在例如某个年龄之前开始吸烟，成瘾率接近18%。事实上，如果你在14、15岁左右开始吸烟，你的成瘾率会更高，达到25%的人尝试后会成瘾。因此，存在一些敏感期，在这些时期你更有可能患上大麻使用障碍。
With that said, people always like to put this within context. Alcohol is more addictive. Nicotine is the most addictive, about three quarters of the people who try and nicotine become addictive. But it's similar to other drugs that are legal, slightly less addictive than alcohol and nicotine. Are there risk factors for, you know, who may become more addicted, especially among teenagers? One of them is having comorbid psychiatric disorders. So individuals with the diagnosis, for example, of schizophrenia or depression may have more problems related to their cannabis use and thus more likely to develop cannabis use disorders.
话虽如此，人们总是喜欢在背景中看待这一点。酒精更容易成瘾。尼古丁是最容易成瘾的，大约四分之三尝试尼古丁的人都会上瘾。但它类似于其他合法的药物，成瘾性略低于酒精和尼古丁。是否存在关于谁可能更容易上瘾的危险因素，特别是在青少年中？其中之一是共患精神疾病。例如，被诊断患有精神分裂症或抑郁症的个人可能会遇到更多与大麻使用相关的问题，因此更有可能发展为大麻使用障碍。
There's also an African American and Hispanic adolescents and young adults if they have a lot of arrests in their past. And this is where the criminal justice part of it comes in and that might actually getting rid of some of those criminal justice components might actually be protective against developing problems. Some other risk factors are being very impulsive. Being someone who's sensation seeking, you may be more likely to try something like marijuana. But sensation seekers actually think about the consequences. The difference is if you're impulsive, you try something, you don't really think about the consequences, and those folks are more likely to develop dependence and use disorders.
此外，非裔美国人和西班牙裔青少年及年轻人如果在过去有很多逮捕记录。这就是刑事司法部分发挥作用的地方，摆脱其中一些刑事司法组成部分实际上可能对防止产生问题起到保护作用。其他一些危险因素包括非常冲动。作为一个寻求刺激的人，你可能更有可能尝试大麻之类的事情。但寻求刺激的人实际上会考虑后果。区别在于，如果你很冲动，你尝试了某些事情，你并没有真正考虑后果，而这些人更有可能产生依赖和使用障碍。
Thankfully, the majority of teenagers don't become dependents. There's a huge segment, at least half, that don't even try marijuana or really other drugs. We are trying to really figure out what puts someone on the track of trying it, that kind of first stage and really enjoying it and it being really rewarding, and then going on and using it regularly, therefore kind of changing the structure of the brain and sensitizing the brain to the drug and then using compulsively and really showing a cannabis use disorder. And so there are some longitudinal studies right now really trying to figure that out. So what predicts what trajectory you get on? And also what's so protective? We know that parental involvement, community norms that say that cannabis is harmful, help reduce the likelihood of you using, and also being involved with a lot of other activities,
值得庆幸的是，大多数青少年并没有产生依赖。有很大一部分人，至少有一半人甚至不尝试大麻或真正尝试其他药物。我们正试图弄清楚是什么让某人走上了尝试的轨道，那种最初的阶段并真正享受它并觉得它非常具有奖励性，然后继续并定期使用它，从而改变大脑结构并使大脑对药物敏感，然后强迫性地使用并真正表现出大麻使用障碍。因此，目前有一些纵向研究正在努力弄清楚这一点。那么，是什么预测了你走上的轨迹？还有什么是具有保护作用的？我们知道父母的参与、认为大麻有害的社区规范有助于降低你使用的可能性，并且参与很多其他活动，
especially physical activities and also religious activities are protective. Great. Well, thank you, Dr. Liz Doll for joining us. Thank you. For more information on marijuana use and teens, visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
特别是体育活动以及宗教活动，都具有保护作用。太好了。好的，谢谢利兹达尔博士加入我们的节目。谢谢。有关青少年大麻使用的更多信息，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学解密》。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。